mr auteur
le député libéral anthony rota a été
réélu président de la chambre des
communes pour la première fois en plus
d'un an et demi presque tous les députés
étaient présents en personne à la
chambre des communes c'était aussi le
début des travaux au sénat en prévision
du discours du trône qui aura lieu
demain
alors avec nous ce soir l'économiste
clément gignac tout nouveau sénateur
assermentés cet après-midi représentants
de la division québec au québec qui lie
sénateur indépendant du groupe
progressiste du sénat les présentations
sont faites honorable clément gignac
bonsoir ou après mais plus que les mains
soient mes super league bonsoir climat
giec ce plaisir de vous retrouver parce
que on vous a tellement été roger à
notre antenne pour nous expliquer
l'économie notamment durant toute la
période de pandémie vous voilà sénateurs
comment vous vous sentez
dans ce nouveau rôle mais évidemment
c'est une certaine fierté mais aussi je
vois un polo qui est associé aux du
sénateur parce que vous savez c'est un
rôle de second regard sur les
législations que le gouvernement peut
présenter donc nous on est l'oeuvre et
même poser des questions s'assurer des
choses vont se font correctement vous
vous l'avez signalé durant pandémie j'ai
même appuyé jusqu'à un certain point le
gouvernement que c'étaient les bonnes
choses à faire mais maintenant faut
qu'on s'entende sur une trajectoire
durable au niveau des finances publiques
il faudra mener con qu'on sécurise parce
que il ya quand même des générations
futures puis d'autres enjeux il ya aussi
des changements climatiques donc il ya
vraiment un rôle important comme senna
tu as réussi à te voilà c'est justin
trudeau qui vous a nommé mais ça ne fait
pas de vous un sénateur
libéral parce qu'il n'y a plus de
sénateurs associé au parti libéral on
vous dit progressiste ou membres du
groupe progresser ça veut dire quoi bien
que dans le fond c'est que on n'est pas
là pour mettre des bâtons dans
les jambes du gouvernement m'ont hélas
quand même poser les bonnes questions et
vous savez dans le groupe des
progressistes maintenant il ya dizaine
bellemare que vous connaissez bien
l'économie ce que j'ai joint aux gros
donc on est en haut de la gorge jusqu'à
la droite de toutes les couleurs au
niveau du bobo progressiste un petit
groupe de quinze groupes 15 personnes
pourquoi je les joints c'est parce qu'on
va collaborer ensemble pour mettre
ensemble nos projets de recherche donc
il va avoir un travail d'équipé qui va
se faire donc c'est pour ça que je les
joints et je contemple leye signaler que
c'est quand même un processus de
nomination est dépendant fallait
appliquer et un comité de cinq personnes
de sélection indépendant qui auront
commandé mon nom 1er mai noté mais il ya
un groupe de sénateurs qui demeure
conservateur associé au parti
conservateur qui est très bien organisée
qui est synchronisé avec l'opposition
affichée lors ce power est ce que vous
vous avez confiance dans la capacité des
deux chambres de procéder rondement à
l'examen des projets de loi qui sont
importants pour les canadiens ouais j'ai
confiance premièrement sur les 180
sénateurs faut penser que ya déjà 60
nominations qui ont des fêtes depuis
2015 que c'est des sénateurs
indépendants
c'est des jeunes majorité le groupe des
conservateurs fait allusion c'est moins
de 20 percent 20 sénateurs maintenant
donc la majorité de la chambre est
devenue indépendante
donc vous savez faut avoir des a besoin
non pas de deux ans faut avoir des
horizons de 5 à 10 ans on veut faire
progresser le pays puis que ce soit au
niveau des enjeux liés au climat et au
changement climatique ou finances
publiques là pour laisser les finances
publiques en bonheur pour nos petits
enfants mais froide et horizon plus long
terme pour mieux se faire la personne
ride comme comme économiste vous avez
effectivement souvent expliqué combien
c'est important durant la pandémie
de s'endetter d'emprunter pour investir
dans l'économie pour aider lige est ce
que là à 150 milliards de déficit vous
êtes inquiet est ce que vous allez faire
une pression particulière pour qu'on
revienne au déficit zéro comme vous
voyez les choses même prégnant mais
peut-être que je pense que dans
prochaines années il faudra qu'on ait de
la part du gouvernement un plan crédible
de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire non
pas dans les deux prochaines années mais
d'avoir au moins un horizon sur 5 1 donc
ça c'est très important
et là dessus on heureux des questions
posées il faudra s'assurer également
dans le dossier des changements
climatiques que les les bébés que les
bottines suivent les babines parce que
c'est vous à avoir des projets pour
réduire les gaz à effet de serre mais
est ce que vraiment on est des plans
crédibles par rapport à nos objectifs
donc comme sénateur on est là aussi
poser les bonnes questions qu'on est là
également pour représenter les intérêts
du québec parce que je suis un sénateur
du québec donc remise en jeu qui voce
notamment de la province de québec et là
dessus on est là pour défendre les
intérêts vous vous sentez libre d'agir
comme vous voulez comme sénateur oui on
est totalement indépendant et donc lui
c'est encore plus vrai avec le processus
de nomination qui était bon et vous
savez moi j'ai des amis peu importe les
partis politiques l'important c'est d'y
aller selon notre conscience
professionnelle et s'assurer qu'on est
sur des territoires durables mais aussi
d'avoir des reprises son inclusive parce
que discours de la société comptait
laisser vos comptes des secteurs aussi
car encore des moments plus difficiles
dont vous assurez le condamnerait prise
inclusive mais aussi qui est durable
entend c'est quoi votre objectif comme
sénateur quand vous voyez juste pendant
cinq ans dans dix ans combien de temps
vous voulez être au sénat où vous allez
et hausse énorme c'est quoi votre
objectif clément gignac bien
premièrement il ya différents comités
gerald comme vous savez il ya celui ci
finances publiques ont peut-être dans
cinq ans ou dans huit ans de faire
participer d'être président d'un comité
sénatorial si mes collègues sont
d'accord avec çà donc de pouvoir
participer parce que là ce moment là on
est beaucoup plus d' influence sur le
l'agenda du gouvernement que ce soit au
niveau de l'invitation des témoins ou
aussi pour les véhicules législation
donc moi c'est vraiment finances
publiques et les enjeux reliés aux
changements climatiques et c'est pour ça
que également commencé ministre des
ressources naturelles au québec j'ai
demandé à ce que je peut siéger sur le
comité de l'environnement et des
ressources naturelles d'autant plus
qu'on ne mène à seven guide book vient
d'être nommé minutes environnement et
leurs chiens que l'action on va passer
de la petite vitesse à la grande vitesse
alors en grande vitesse on vous laisse
aller clément gignac ce sera un plaisir
de vous interroger à quelques reprises
dans le futur comme sénateur merci bonne
chance merci votre invitation de là pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne
hier d